I'm trying to find a way we can lift the
burden off the shoulders of black people
of white
supremacy what if we skip over all that
hoping what if we skip over all of the
pleading and the begging and the
marching and the shouting and go
straight to the power during a great
migration about 6 million black people
left the South for cities in the north
and west I suggest that black people
return to the states with the highest
percentages already of black people
where they can gain political power if
we're going to make a go of it the South
makes a lot of
sense I was shaken and nervous maybe
even afraid about leaving New York for
Atlanta I've have convinced myself that
this is what we must do as black people
I don't know if you could convince that
many people to move that way the
argument of like hey go south is that
much different from hey up north let's
get this together you are encouraging
black Chicago to stay here stay intact
this our
city I want for black boys to live in a
world where they do not have to think
about protecting their Humanity those
who don't want to see sharing of that
power will do all that they can to
waylay that situation there is The X
Factor of these voter suppression bills
every freedom is at
State there are some things in life that
are bigger than you it has to be
about Community success we are the
calvary we've been waiting on I have to
figure out if I am being an apostle of
black power or am I chasing windmills we
got to get back and
claim really what we
[Music]
built